when we talk about the AFC North it's
been brown Steelers Ravens brown
Steelers Ravens and the Bengals bro
saying hey what about us or maybe
they're happy to not be paid much
attention because they can go about
their business undeterred or undisturbed
or uninterrupted or on something I don't
know yeah unprofessional would be that
last five seconds for me anyway the this
great this is all live to tape so if I
screw up we can't fix it I used to do
these Chris by the way I used to do
these VOD segments like one after
another and and so if you miss speak you
just start the whole thing over cuz it's
two minutes long so this is great I mean
we can't there's no second take we go
yeah anyway the Bengals are installing
their offense in a different kind of a
way instead of installing it by position
group specifically Albert Brewer of
si.com points out they are installing
the offense completely yeah together all
right
players understanding the whole offense
instead of narrowing the plays down to
how it affects a certain group of
players right is that how unusual is
that and are there are there benefits
and are there disadvantages to doing
yeah I think it goes on maybe a little
bit more than people would realize there
are benefits certainly you know that I
think this is the big thing you're
learning the offense in its totality
you're getting to hear the language and
its fullness all the time you know a
receiver you know more times than not
just wants to hear his one little part
oh I got this route and let me break the
huddle but when you are learning a new
system you know you can start to put the
rhyme and reasons together of why
certain things are called this and why
they're called that you learn the
history of the offense you might want to
go wait why do we call this route this
and then we do a certain route that's
very similar to it but we call it
something completely different and the
coach might explain to you well you know
this is where the origin of this play
came from or you know hey the offensive
line has a similar call to the word
you're saying we should use so therefore
we went with another word and you start
to understand and really digest the
offense and its totality a lot better
that way
so I do think you'll have a better
understanding all the time instead of
you just learning your one little thing
you need to learn about now at some
point the receivers are going into their
wide
room and they're talking about exactly
what they have to do but it sounds like
they're having a lot of offensive full
offensive meetings where they're
teaching everybody a little bit of
everything and usually within those
meetings Mike the position coaches are
sitting close to their players to to
talk little finer details out in the
meeting room as they go along if you
know let's say Zack Taylor's talking
about the offensive line the wide
receiver coach can quietly whisper to
the wide receivers hey hey you know this
this and this means that and don't
forget your rules and it's a good way to
put the offense and sorry for the
long-winded answer and I like on one
hand the idea of everyone knowing what
everyone else is doing but on the other
hand you know what yeah
if I'm split left eye hey there's a lot
going on forty yards away from me that
it's completely irrelevant to my
assignment on this play I think there's
a certain value in being laser focused
on what you are asked to do and it's up
to the coaches to make sure the 11
players weave together but I get I guess
from the perspective of when things go
haywire which they often do right if you
have an understanding of what the other
guys are doing then maybe you can react
more quickly but my god to carry around
in your head all of that information for
every play that gets called I just think
that's unrealistic yeah well listen
they're not sitting there like really
dialed in to what the offensive line
calls are they're just going oh okay I
hear that and oh now I know to listen to
my part at the wide receiver position
but what it does to mic you know the
learning of the formations and things
like that
you know you could be the split out
receiver to the left all game law of all
game long and all of a sudden let's just
say there's an injury at the wide
receiver position right the slot
receiver got injured all of a sudden
you've got to move into the slot and man
there's some different rules for the
slot receiver and the language is a
little different and you know when we're
in this formation there's little nuances
that you have to know and I think that's
where it's great to meet as a total
offense as you just get to you know
learn some of the things that you'd
normally wouldn't learn from when the
time comes that they might ask you hey
we need you here it won't be such a
drastic change or so shocking let's not
go completely to sleep on the Cincinnati
Rose they I think that's the best
situation to be in where no one
spec's anything out of you you can get
your guys pissed off because they're
being overlooked you
chip-on-the-shoulder you don't have the
expectations that the Browns have maybe
the Bengals can surprise some people
this year and maybe and if they do I
guarantee you this more teams will be
implementing their offenses this way if
it works for the Bengals that's how it
goes in the NFL right Chris no you're
right more teams ago okay wow that
worked and you know if we start to hear
continue to hear players talk positively
about it and the experience of learning
that way you're right it will catch on
with the NFL but Mike main point what
you said I love it and you're right man
anybody out there don't sleep on the
Bengals look at the Bengals roster
they're still studs all over the place I
mean that's why the AFC North is just
unbelievable you know yeah the Bengals
are in the basement but there's there's
Pro Bowlers and Hall of Famers on this
roster you know with guys like AJ green
and Geno Atkins and Carlos Dunlap and
Kirkpatrick and William Jackson and Joe
Mixon you started to go through it you
go Wow okay this is not like the worst
team we've ever seen so I would not be
shocked if they were you know pretty
damn good this year yeah but they
weren't good last year I mean but that's
the thing look III said this recently
you could have 32 teams that have Bill
Belichick and Tom Brady on the payroll
and you could have the entire you could
you could make duplicates of all the
players on the Patriots and have 32
teams and they're still gonna be teams
that are four and twelve yeah there's
just certain things that happen over the
course of whether it's scheduling bad
luck bad calls untimely mistakes stuff
happens and a lot of times it's that
stuff that happens a little bit here and
a little bit there that makes a team
that would be ten and six six and ten
and and that's just the reality and the
Bengals were bad last year but it
doesn't take much to turn it around
that's why so many teams didn't make the
playoffs one year end up in the
postseason the next year no you're
exactly right
I mean you refocused human emotions
players coaches everybody's focused
there's edge you know within the
building in this scenario with the
bangles it's new coaches its new life
it's new energy it's oh let me impress
my new coach let me impress my new head
coach so everything is on the up-and-up
in that organization right now to where
yeah they're learning new things
our evaluating new players players are
trying to impress the new coaches and a
lot of the times that leads to
successful things once the season comes
around
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports